الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قال نائب في مجلس الدومه الروسي ان
عبوه ناسفه انفجرت في مصفاه نفط بمدينه
سماره الجنوبيه روسيا دون وقوع عصابات في
الوقت نفسه اعلنت خدمه الطوارئ الروسيه عن
اصابه خمسه عشر شخصا نتيجه انفجار بمقهى
في مدينه تاغون روك بمقاطعه روستوف
الجنوبيه البلاد وقالت وسائل اعلام
الروسيه ان الانفجار وقع وسط المدينه وان
السيارات الاسعاف وفرق الاطفاء وصلت الى
المكان من جانبيه قال حاكم مقاطعه رستوف
الانفجار قد يكون ناجما عن اطلاق صاروخ
وميدانيا في اوكرانيا قال المتحدث باسم
قوات الغرب في الجيش الروسي سيركيز بنيسكي
قال ان قوتهم نفذت هجمات على مواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في محور كوبيانسكاب
واضافينسكي ان وحده الدبابات والطيران
الحربي الروسيه نفذت عمليات هجوميه على
مواقع اوكرانيه في مناطق بخار كييف
في سياق الاعمال العسكريه باتجاه كوبيانسك
وجهت القوات الصاروخيه لمجموعه قوات الغرب
ضربه صاروخيه في منطقه بلاغوداتانا حيث
تتمركز وحدات من اللواء الالي الاوكراني
كما وجهت قوات الدبابات ضربات الى وحدات
اللواء الميكانيكي في مناطق ادت الى تدمير
عدد من الاليات العسكريه وشن الطائرات
الهليكوبتر الهجوميه التابعه لقوات الغرب
9 ضربات جويه على تجمع للقوات الاوكرانيه
ووحده دفاع اقليمي بالمنطقه
من جهتها قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه من
القوات الروسيه اعتقد ثلاثه صواريخ ونفذت
29 غاره جويه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه كما
اعتقد اكثر من 70 قذيفه من راجمات
الصواريخ خلال الساعات 24 الماضيه واضافت
الهيئه ان قواتها السيطره على قريه ستارو
مايورسكو بمقاطعه دونيسكا وتصدت لمحاولات
التقدم الروسيه في لمان في المقاطعه نفسها
بينما نفذت القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما على
محوري ميلتوبول
وبيردن في مقاطعه